et hydrogène vert à inaugurer une
nouvelle phase de ces travaux davantage
tourné vers les producteurs après avoir
entendu hier la FNSEA et ses
organisations spécialisées nous recevons
aujourd'hui deux groupes majeurs engie
puis à 18h total énergie nous entendrons
également la semaine prochaine
EDF et R liquide s'agit Jean du groupe
engie nous avons le plaisir de recevoir
Monsieur Sébastien arbolat directeur
général adjoint en cherche des activités
de production thermique et de
fournitures d'énergie courant notamment
l'hydrogène
monsieur Herbelin est accompagné de
Monsieur Thierry rat et velle
directeur des relations parlementaires
et des territoires que nous avons
rencontré la semaine dernière en
visitant la station de recharge
d'hydrogène de Saint-Priest
une des communes de la métropole de Lyon
avec sa casquette ce jour-là de
Président
nous avons ainsi pu observer sur le
terrain une action concrète menée par
votre groupe en matière développement de
la mobilité hydrogène dans le cadre
d'une alliance originale avec la région
Auvergne Rhône-Alpes l'ADEME la banque
des territoires le groupe Michelin et le
Crédit Agricole je rappelle que notre
réunion cette réunion est captée et
diffusée en direct sur le site internet
du Sénat sur lequel
elle pourra ensuite être consultée en
vidéo à la demande elle est également
rediffusée ou diffusée en direct sur
plusieurs réseaux sociaux Facebook
Twitter YouTube et lin
messieurs notre mission d'information
comprend des membres
issus des différentes commissions du
Sénat et qui représentent l'ensemble des
groupes politiques qui composent le
Sénat le développement des filières de
biocarburant de carburant synthétique
durable et d'hydrogène vert représente
un enjeu important pour permettre à la
France et à l'Union européenne
d'atteindre l'objectif de neutralité
carbone à l'horizon 2050 mais aussi pour
notre souveraineté et la compétitivité
de notre économie nous avons jusqu'à
présent tendu de nombreux acteurs
publics qui se penchent sur les
stratégies à mettre en oeuvre que ce
soit en France ou comme nous l'avons
fait en début de semaine à Bruxelles
c'est évidemment fondamental puisque
dénégociations importantes sont en cours
de finalisation au niveau de l'Union
européenne nous avons également
entendu des centres de réflexion et des
organismes de recherche
je tourne ma page blanche
il nous est important d'entendre
maintenant d'avoir la vision des
industriels et singulièrement des
producteurs d'énergie pour comprendre
comment vous vous adaptez à l'ambition
européenne qui se dessine pour apprécier
ce que représente l'hyperspectives de
développement d'hydrogène vert et des
carburants de synthèse dans le
portefeuille d'activités d'un groupe
comme engie mais aussi pour analyser ce
qui peut aujourd'hui freiner le
développement de ces filières que ce
soit sur le plan réglementaire sur le
plan technique ou long terme
d'accompagnement fiscal ou financier
nous avons bien conscience que la France
et l'Union européenne n'évolue pas dans
une bulle isolée du reste du monde et
que nous devons faire face à des
stratégies de développement industriel
très ambitieux voire agressif de la part
de certains états je pense évidemment à
l'inflation réduction à American
l'hydrogène vert et les carburants de
synthèse sont appelés à contribuer de
manière significative à la décarbonation
de certains modes de transport et en
particulier des modes de transport lourd
plusieurs personnes additionnées ont
toutefois souligné la rareté des
ressources disponibles nous serons donc
attentifs à votre analyse en ce qui
concerne notamment par rapport à
d'autres usages qui pourraient également
s'avérer pertinent en particulier pour
décarboner l'industrie
notre rapporteur monsieur Vincent capot
canelas qui est à l'origine de cette
mission d'information vous a adressé un
questionnaire qui peut vous servir de
guide mais
vous sentez libre de
d'envisager votre propos
introductif je passerai ensuite la
parole à notre rapporteur puis à
l'ensemble de mes collègues afin qu'ils
puissent vous relancer et vous poser un
certain nombre de questions vous pouvez
nous transmettre
ultérieurement des réponses écrites aux
questions qui vous ont été adressées par
notre rapporteur monsieur arbelin je
vous cède la parole
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur messieurs les sénateurs engie
est très honoré d'abord de participer à
cette audition aujourd'hui sur les
biocarburants les carburants de synthèse
et hydrogène vert je suis ravi aussi que
vous avez pu venir sur le terrain à
Saint-Priest je croyais il y a quelques
semaines la semaine dernière pour voir
sur le terrain de station de recharge
d'hydrogène c'est le réseau un pulsion
dont nous sommes actionnaires et que
nous développons dans la région Auvergne
Rhône-Alpes alors peut-être si vous me
permettez avant de rentrer dans le sujet
de précis de l'audition qui est plus un
sujet transport j'aimerais recadrer les
ambitions d'engie sur les biocarburants
et l'hydrogène vert et petite précision
liminaire quand il s'agit de
biocarburant chez engie on parle de
biométhane donc nous ne sommes pas dans
la production de biofioul autre que du
mieux méthane et sur l'hydrogène nous ne
sommes pas aujourd'hui producteur
d'hydrogène à base d'énergie fossiles
donc quand je parle d'hydrogène c'est
hydrogène bas carbone hydrogène
renouvelable engie à l'ambition d'être
présent sur toute la chaîne de valeur du
biométhane et d'hydrogène renouvelable
bas carbone et NJ dispose en fait de
compétences spécifiques pour pouvoir
adresser ses projets là donc à la valve
de la chaîne de valeur à la montre la
chaîne valeur désolé nous sommes l'un
des principaux développeurs
renouvelables et vous le savez l'énergie
renouvelable est un des points les plus
importants pour produire l'hydrogène
renouvelable nous sommes d'ailleurs le
premier producteur d'énergie
renouvelable solaire et vent en France
avec 5 gigawatts de capacité à installer
et nous sommes aussi international un
acteur majeur nous avons l'ambition en
2030 de développer des capacités de 80
GW qui est très important ce qui va nous
aider bien sûr dans ces projets là alors
à Laval ce qui est important aussi c'est
que nous sommes le principal opérateur
d'infrastructure gazières en France vous
le savez un transport stockage et
distribution je vais revenir et nous
sommes aussi à Laval aujourd'hui un
client clé des collectivités locales et
des grands industries y pour pouvoir
proposer de l'électricité et de la
chaleur et ce sont ces mêmes clients et
collectivités qui viennent nous voir
depuis quelques années pour des
carbonées leurs usages et donc ce
faisant nous sommes légitime légitimes à
proposer ce type de solution alors fort
de cela indice est fixé l'objectif
d'atteindre une capacité annuelle dans
le biométhane de type
en Europe en 2030 dont la moitié en
Europe non la moitié en France donc
dites à water en Europe en 2030 et donc
cinq terawattheure en France et donc cet
effort ça correspond à peu près à une
part de marché de 10%, donc nous tablons
une période de marché de 10% et ça
correspond à 3 milliards
d'investissements sur la période 2023
jusqu'à 2030 en cumulé en matière
d'hydrogène vert principalement et bas
carbone donc ici engie vise à des
carbone des carboniser principalement
l'industrie ses clients industriels et
aussi à participer à les carbonisations
du transport et là nous avons
tout un set de d'objectif le premier
d'entre eux et la production d'hydrogène
renouvelable de 4 gigawatts en 2030 nous
avons aussi comme objectif de développer
700 km de réseau de transport en 2030 un
térawater de stockage d'hydrogène et
aussi sans station similaire à celle que
vous avez vu l'ensemble de ces ambitions
porte à 4 milliards en plus des 3
milliards dont je parlais pour lui
méthane l'effort d'investissement donc
c'est un effort cumulé de 7 milliards de
2023 à 2030 en cumulé
et notre vision en été sur le
l'hydrogène c'est qu'il y a un
développement local qui se perd déjà à
travers les collectivités territoriales
surtout sur le transport
et qu'en parallèle de ça il y a un fort
besoin dans les les nœuds et les
territoires industriels notamment près
des ports et donc ça ça arrive assez
vite mais que dans un second temps
peut-être le moyen terme il y aura
une expansion de ces développements
hydrogène et pour que cette expansion
arrive il faudra des infrastructures en
parallèle de ça parce qu'effectivement
la France est dans un marché européen et
l'Europe est aussi un marché mondial on
le voit il y a des projets d'export très
importants dans des pays qui ont la
chance d'avoir des renouvelables
abondants sur abondant je dirais et pas
cher donc en fait les deux arrivent en
parallèle aussi bien la production
locale pour la consommation locale ce
qu'on voit aujourd'hui en Europe
principalement dans les hub en France
notamment les portes et c'est le cas de
engie on développe nos projets
principalement dans les ports pour
l'industrie en plus de des mariages
territorial pour la partie transport
mais c'est vrai aussi en Belgique au
Pays-Bas en Allemagne où les ports sont
vraiment un des points importants et
puis on va en parler de ça je me répète
mais que certains pays qui sur abondance
de renouvelable essaye de la valoriser
en essayant de travailler sur les
chaînes d'export pour démarcher
États-Unis Asie mais aussi Europe qui
auront besoin d'une molécule qui sera
produite à battre hydrogène mais qui
sera soit de lamoniaque synthétique soit
de les mettre canal synthétique soit du
kérosène synthétique donc maintenant si
je reviens à la au thème de la mission
qui porte plus sur les transports nous
pensons chez engie qui a besoin
d'électrification massive du marché mais
aussi de gaz vert pour des carboner des
transports industrie ce sont deux
secteurs qui sont difficiles à
décarboner comme vous le savez et qui
représente quand même 30% des gaz à
effet de serre donc c'est pas
négligeable et je j'ajouterai aussi que
pour les transports c'est le seul
secteur qui a vu ses émissions de gaz à
effet de serre augmentait
continuellement si je mets de côté la
période covid donc il y a vraiment
urgence à trouver des solutions et c'est
là-dessus que nous y attelons alors bien
sûr les solutions dépendront des
vecteurs énergétiques et des usages donc
ce que nous voyons c'est que pour un
usage véhicule individuel nous voyons
l'électricité donc électrification
directe comme étant le moyen le plus le
plus efficace parce que effectivement
c'est le plus avancé c'est aussi là où
l'autonomie pose moins de problèmes et
où la force motrice c'est aussi pas pas
trop un sujet par contre quand il s'agit
du transport lourd au transport à Ford
puissance motrice donc je parle par
exemple des sérieux les valateurs je
parle des camions je parle des trains
pour tout ce qui est tout ce qui est
terrestre là on voit l'hydrogène comme
étant un élément important de de
l'équation et puis au-delà de ça pour ce
qui est bateau et avion là on parle de
l'hydrogène mais sous forme d'un vecteur
qui est autre qui sera probablement
alors pour le maritime il y a encore un
débat entre limetta niethanol mais en
tout cas il y a des commandes de bateaux
importantes qui ont été faites sur les
deux donc on verra bien le les deux ont
besoin d'hydrogène renouvelables donc en
fait ont été pour hydrogène ça change
pas grand chose pour l'avion aujourd'hui
on voit que liquet Rosen et ce que
demande les compagnies aériennes le plus
souvent pour réutiliser
les moteurs et réutiliser
l'infrastructure qui est aujourd'hui en
place et donc c'est c'est ça notre
vision des choses
alors peut-être si si je dois revenir
au-delà du transport un peu la vision
d'engie sur ces deux marchés qui sont le
biométhane et l'hydrogène donc côté
biométhane la fièvre française a un an
d'avance sur la PPE ce qui est bien et
nous sommes très motivés pour développer
cette filière plus avant donc
aujourd'hui le biométhane de génération
1 celle qui c'est qui utilise en fait
les déchets agricoles et déchets
alimentaires et mature il n'y a pas de
conflit d'usage avec les autres filières
qui utilisent la biomasse et donc on
pense qu'à l'horizon 2030 le potentiel
de biométhane génération 1 et de couvrir
20% de la consommation de gaz en France
qui correspond à 60 terawattheure et
donc ça on pense que dans la nouvelle
PPE il faudrait qu'il y ait des
objectifs réhaussés par rapport à ce qui
est prévu aujourd'hui d'ailleurs on est
on est en avance donc ça pourrait
légitimité légitimer cela côté hydrogène
donc je l'ai dit on voit un
développement en deux temps le premier
temps c'est le temps qu'on voit
aujourd'hui le développement à court
terme des écosystèmes hydrogène
régionaux et puis complété par les
écosystèmes industriels notamment dans
le dans des hubs et puis après on voit
effectivement que ces écosystèmes
hydrogène devront se relier entre eux
pour pouvoir effectivement faire part
aux nouveaux usages les nouveaux usages
ce sera la mobilité la mobilité comme
vous le savez et comme électrique a
besoin d'un mariage précis de station de
recharge et puis dans le plus long terme
on voit aussi que les infrastructure
serviront notamment avec le stockage
service
la production électrique aujourd'hui
faite à base de gaz de gaz naturel et ça
sera probablement fait à base de gaz
naturel soit vert soit l'hydrogène mais
c'est pour ça il faut bien sûr des
infrastructures en place
et puis bien sûr on le voit en parallèle
que ce marché l'hydrogène et ses dérivés
va se développer dans d'autres pays dans
d'autres zones et donc il faut avoir
bien conscience tout à chacun que il
faut il faut qu'on soit compétitif dans
notre sourcing de pour la biomasse mais
aussi sur signe de projet pour être
certain que les filières françaises
d'excellence qui sont partis avant les
autres et les robes est partie avant les
autres régions du monde puisse en
bénéficier alors peut-être un petit
petite pause sur nos projets quel projet
nous développons et Kenji qu'est-ce que
c'est une vie fait aujourd'hui dans ce
monde-là biométhane et hydrogène donc
dans le biométhane peut-être pour
peut-être avant ça peut-être pour un
petit point de de bielle et qui est très
important donc nous nous développons pas
pour nos besoins propres parce que nous
avons notre propre trajectoire des
carbonations qui est plutôt sur plus de
renouvelables moins moins de gaz mais
comme ça pour nos clients donc nous
sommes en fait à l'écoute de nos clients
et nous des développons les projets que
nos clients nous demandent et les
clients ils demandent aujourd'hui du
volume à tous les clients demandent de
hydrogène et du gaz vert ils demandent
de la certitude d'avoir ce volume à
temps parce que ils anticipe un projet
d'écarbonation il
le promettent à l'actionnaire et auprès
de parti prenantes mais aujourd'hui la
partie exécution est pas totalement
calée ils veulent un prix qui soit
raisonnablement compétitif donc ça il y
a un assez grand différence entre
l'industrie qui doit remplacer
l'hydrogène aujourd'hui qui est carbonée
où il y a un prix de référence parce que
c'est souvent une transformation un
produit transformé donc il produit final
n'est pas celui-là et donc là il y a une
compétition mondiale par exemple les
engrais où il nous demande effectivement
de d'avoir le même prix de l'hydrogène
carbonée et d'hydrogène des carbonée
parce qu'ils finait les engrais est un
marché mondial et donc ils doivent se
battre contre des têtes des audio
graphiques qui ont pas cette ambition de
décarbonation et puis les transports ou
là les transports nos clients voient
quand même cette prime qui est liée à
une molécule verte pourra être
rebalancer sur le client final de façon
plus facile et d'ailleurs ils ne sont
pas en compétition vers l'hydrogène
carbonée mais en compétition vers autre
chose du kérosène du diesel avec tous
les sujets de souveraineté énergétique
d'indépendance énergétique et la crise
ukrainienne nous a aussi montré que ces
sources ou ses produits peuvent fluctuer
à la hausse ou à la baisse donc ils sont
très intéressés par ça donc maintenant
si je regarde
nos projets à travers le monde donc le
biométhane nous avons 600 GW avec 20
méthaniseurs en France aujourd'hui
installés nous visons comme je l'ai déjà
dit nous visons en fait une accélération
de cette capacité de production de
biométhane aujourd'hui le cadre
législatif on s'en fait on s'en félicite
a fait des grands pas en avant ce qui me
semble important pour une bonne
efficacité mais c'est aussi ce que fait
le gouvernement français c'est d'avoir
d'un côté des certificats de production
biométhane qui sont de traçabilité et
une authentification de durabilité et
puis de l'autre côté des obligations
d'un incorporation et donc ça ça permet
quand même d'accélérer comme on l'a vu
sur d'autres filières un fortement la
production et aussi d'assurer en fait
une un certificat de durabilité qui soit
échangeable et qui soit qui soit le même
partout donc ça on s'en félicite
maintenant on attend les décrets les
applications mais ça va dans le bon sens
donc ça c'est sur la sur la première
génération deuxième génération qui qui
diffèrent dans le sens où on utilise de
la biomasse qui vient plutôt du bois et
des ce qu'on appelle le CSR en
combustible solides de récupération ça
c'est encore un peu moins mature donc et
on s'attend quand même à ce que ça ça
décolle et donc dans le débat PPE SNBC
qui qui va commencer qui est un con
c'est bientôt nous on estime qu'il y a à
peu près 300 terwatts de biomasse
qui qui peut être utilisé pour pour le
biométhane donc 140 sur la première
génération et puis après le reste sur la
deuxième génération et une autre partie
40 terwatthers sur la méta-nation voilà
donc cette vision donc on a une vision
très très volontariste et on s'y attelle
d'ailleurs sur la partie deuxième
génération nous avons un projet au Havre
moi j'ai ça la bande qui qui est bien
parti et c'est Emma CGM que vous
connaissez nous avons conclu avec eux un
partenariat pour 200000 tonnes par an de
GNL à l'horizon par an à l'horizon 2030
donc c'est concret
alors à partir de à partir de là si on
fait un zoom sur les sujets plutôt
hydrogène
donc aujourd'hui le marché de
l'hydrogène donc sert surtout à des
carboner l'industrie qui utilisent
aujourd'hui
l'hydrogène gris donc carbonée
d'autres secteurs industriels qui ont
besoin de ce décarboner comme l'acier
qui n'utilise pas aujourd'hui
l'hydrogène gris mais qui ont besoin de
changer donc là du enro du charbon avec
un mix gaz et et hydrogène et puis le
troisième secteur qui qui est des
clients potentiels pour nous c'est
vraiment le secteur du transport voilà
donc le transport lourd notamment
maritime mais aussi aussi ferroviaire et
donc aujourd'hui
nous avons des projets dans dans ces
dans toutes ces
ces secteurs là si on commence par
l'industrie nous avons un projet avec
Total je sais que monsieur pouillanet
vient après moi je vous en parlera aussi
mais chez hamacilia donc biographie de
La Mède donc c'est un rétroviseur de 125
mégawatts donc c'est un gros
électrolyseur et des heures de taille
industrielle nous avons reçu de l'aide
de l'État français via les via la
mécanique mécanisme PIAC donc ça y est
en anglais et donc on attend on attend
les fonds on va les recevoir on a une
une communication fluide avec la BPI
donc je ne vois pas de sujet particulier
de ce point de vue là peut-être juste
pour s'arrêter sur ce mécanisme de
subvention européenne avec une pré une
pré sélection à la maille nationale
après une validation à la maille
européenne et un retour dans les États
membres ça prend beaucoup de temps donc
ça prend en gros 18 mois
en 18 mois le marché a décalé le marché
de renouvelable à décaler parce que avec
la crise ukrainienne et donc on voit
bien que les calculs qui sous tendaient
un projet qui sous tente ce type de
projet
à un instant T si jamais on a la réponse
une visibilité à tes plus 18 mois on
voit bien que ça pose des problèmes d'un
point de vue
décisionnaire donc ça c'est un message
que je vais faire passer je crois que
c'est formidable outils
qui fonctionne bien une fois qu'on est
validé mais le temps le temps est assez
long donc on a pour ce type de projet
donc des carbone et les raffineries et
les
producteurs d'engrais on a en France
pour projet on a aussi un projet
aujourd'hui en construction d'Australie
avec l'entreprise Yara qui est un
fabricant de d'engrais et donc on voit
bien que les autres zones aussi sont
actives après l'hydrogène peut aussi
servir pour la le transport routier et
ferroviaire donc nous avons aussi un
projet alors plus plus à mon avec Alstom
pour décarboner le ferroviaire sur en
utilisant en fait un bimode pour le
locomotive une partie une partie
électrique conséquent le trajet de
caténaire et une partie sur l'hydrogène
pour les premiers kilomètres et derniers
kilomètres et donc aujourd'hui ça
fonctionne au diesel et donc l'idée
c'est effectivement de remplacer ça pour
les premiers derniers kilomètres en
Europe pour les trains de fret par une
locomotive bimode qui utiliserait
l'électricité tarification et aussi
l'hydrogène donc on travaille avec eux
c'est un exemple nous avons aussi toutes
nos stations de de recharge GNV et
impulsion que vous connaissez et puis
ailleurs aussi de d'Europe nous avons
aujourd'hui des projets en cours donc
sur les chariot élévateurs donc c'est un
détail mais c'est juste pour vous
montrer à quoi sert l'hydrogène donc les
chalets élévateurs de Walmart au Chili
nous avons un projet aujourd'hui actif
et nous avons aussi un projet actif pour
les recherches des camions miniers
d'anglo-américaine en Amérique du Sud
donc c'est un projet pilote qui sert à
recharger un camion mais voilà c'est
pour montrer comment les clients se
positionnent par rapport à ces
différents sujets biocarburant versus
hydrogène et ses dérivés donc là si on
parle de l'hydrogène en tant qu' après
l'hydrogène peut être aussi synthétisée
sous une autre forme et là ce sont les
projets qu'on a sur les qui serviront le
maritime et le et la partie aérien et le
transport aérien on voit je crois qu'il
y a un alignement entre les entre les
compagnies aériennes pour essayer de
fabriquer de lit kérosène parce que
voilà comme je l'ai dit réutilisation
des des moteurs infrastructures et parce
qu'aussi il y a un mandat
d'incorporation rfndo donc des fiouls
des fuels renouvelables d'origine non
biologique qui sont mandatés par le par
l'Union européenne et donc tout ça Aline
les intérêts et les planètes pour pour
le secteur de l'hélium nous avons deux
projets en France pour ce secteur de
l'aérien 1 au Havre c'est le France
kérosène
il s'agit de d'un électrolyseur gros 240
MW et 1 à qui s'appelle rose qui a
Dunkerque pour électrolyseur de 375
mégawatts donc ce sont des gros projets
à taille ind matériel et donc l'idée
c'est de c'est d'éviter par an pour ces
deux projets 1,3 millions de tonnes de
CO2 ce qui est vraiment important pour
le maritime on se concentre sur le
méthanol de synthèse et l'immetane avec
notamment CMA CGM et j'en ai parlé et
puis pour finir sur un panorama de
Global biométhane et hydrogène je
voudrais rappeler quand même les
objectifs de ripower qui viennent de du
plan ripower de l'Union européenne donc
10 millions de tonnes à l'horizon 2030
10 millions de tonnes d'hydrogène
renouvelable produit en Europe et 10
millions de tonnes importés voilà donc
moitié-moitié petite parenthèse pour
dire que 10 millions de tonnes que ce
soit porté ou que ce soit produit en
Europe vu que les mêmes critères vont
s'appliquer ça correspond à 550 tt
d'électricité renouvelable en plus donc
500 + 500 donc c'est quand même l'un des
sujets aussi qu'on voit aujourd'hui
pratiquement dans l'accélération de
cette filière hydrogène et dérivée
d'hydrogène il faut pouvoir
effectivement produire de l'hydrogène à
partir de renouvelable et on est
globalement collectivement en Europe un
peu à court de cette énergie alors il y
a des il y a des plans d'accélération
qui sont en place il y a des volontés
notamment politique qui sont aussi en
place mais il faut le temps que c'est
que les installations soient mises sur
le marché et c'est ce qui freine aussi
un tout petit peu un peu cela donc nous
avons nous aussi pour la partie
importation nous avons des projets
notamment au Chili des projets intégrés
donc qui sont pas raccordés à la grille
électrique de production de l'hydrogène
puis d'une molécule synthétisée à base
de renouvelables différents types de
renouvelables pour essayer justement de
de pallier à l'intermittence naturelle
des renouvelables dans des zones
propices bien entendues ou ces
renouvelables sont pas chers et sont
abondants donc c'est le cas au Chili par
exemple
et pour finir peut-être sur cette
introduction un peu longue je voudrais
revenir sur quelques convictions sur le
marché et la régulation et les éléments
favorables les éléments aussi de blocage
que je vois date donc peut-être pour
dire que la conviction première c'est
que pour que pour qu'on puisse
décarboner rapidement et efficacement
ces secteurs il faut des projets c'est
un peu bête à dire mais il faut des
projets pour qu'il y ait des projets
faut qu'ils aient des projets à
l'échelle des projets qui soient
compétitifs et il faut rapidement donc
ça c'est le plus important et donc les
conditions je voudrais militaire des
deux minutes les conditions de succès
pour ces projets peut-être en commençant
par le biométhane donc aujourd'hui je
l'ai dit les avancées significatives des
cas législatifs français font que on est
assez optimiste s'il y a des mécanismes
certificats de production de biométhane
qui feront en sorte de qualifier la
durabilité de ce biométhane et qui a des
obligations
d'incorporation associés
on l'a vu notamment via les mécanismes
de la thyrowertz pour pour le pour les
biofuels ça fonctionne bien ça fait
porter aussi le coup non plus sur le
budget mais sur les utilisateurs final
et je pense que c'est ça c'est un moyen
d'accélérer très fortement cette ce
secteur là bien sûr il manque quelques
quelques applications le rehaussement du
tarif de rachat devrait être des projets
qui sont inférieurs à 25 gigawh c'est
important il manque aussi la mise en
place de ce fameux mécanisme de
certificat donc certificat donc on
l'appelle le CPB certificat de
production biométhane on attend c'est
très important
mais globalement ça se passe bien
l'autre cadre qui se passe bien et qui
est très important pour aussi
essayer d'animer cette filière sur la
partie recherche innovation c'est ce que
fait l'ADEME donc l'ADEME à plusieurs
plusieurs tuyaux entre guillemets
d'appel à projet il y a les briques
technologiques et démonstrateurs
hydrogène et les écosystèmes
territoriaux ça a bien fonctionné donc
ça je dirais que j'ai pas tellement de
remarques là dessus par contre elle
s'arrête en 2022 et donc là la question
c'est quid de la visibilité que l'on a
sur ce type de d'appel à projet qui est
important pour nourrir globalement la
filière sur la partie recherche
d'innovation donc la partie des du
secteur qui est un peu moins mûr en
termes de technologie
je vois aussi que l'ADEME a lancé
récemment un appel à projet
pour subventionner une filière de
carburant durable pour pour l'aviation
et donc on a participé sur nos deux
projets au Havre et à Dunkerque on a
reçu des fonds d'adem donc ça c'est très
bien le montant sert plutôt à financer
les phases d'études et des phases de
développement mais c'est je trouve que
ça va dans le bon sens
je trouve que ce qui va aussi dans le
bon sens c'est la loi l'accélération sur
les renouvelables parce qu'on touche
l'hydrogène de plusieurs façons mais
déjà elle elle inclut enfin elle
accélère la partie connexion électrique
est un vrai sujet en France donc
aujourd'hui par exemple sur un projet
comme Dunkerque
RTL nous donnait 6 à 7 ans de connexion
d'attentes de cohérent de connexion
électrique donc ça c'est un vrai sujet
cette loi d'accélération pour une un
test de deux ans mais que c'est quand
même marqué dans l'accélération
dit que qui qu'on devra accélérer ça et
qu'il y aura il y aura une une
centralisation des procédures
réglementaires etc donc ça c'est dans le
bon sens je pense le titre important et
puis il y aura effectivement une sorte
de concentration avec un médiation pour
tous les tous les problèmes
d'accélération je pense que ça c'est
très important et le point le plus
important c'est cette accélération de la
disponibilité du renouvelable
parce que comme vous le savez je fais un
petit aparté sur sur plutôt la
réglementation européenne mais qui devra
être transcrite en droit français sur ce
qu'on appelle la red 2 donc la directive
énergie
renouvelable numéro 3 et puis les actes
délégués de la numéro 2 donc on voit que
les ambitions sont très fortement mises
à la hausse donc il faut il faut 49,5%
tout secteur confondus d'énergie
renouvelable à l'horizon 2030 et puis
après il y a des sous soucis par secteur
notamment dans les transports et pour
l'hydrogène renouvelable et les refnbo
il fit aussi via pour l'industrie
et donc ça c'est important c'est
important que la France ait son mix des
carbonées massivement et pu tirer
avantage notamment pour baisser ces
objectifs sectoriels mais quoi qu'il
arrive il faudra quand même beaucoup ne
renouvelables et vite si on veut que
participer en fait à l'établissement de
cette économie d'hydrogène et que
l'hydrogène qui soit produit soit
qualifié de entre guillemets rfnbo parce
que l'un des grands sujets de toutes
toutes développements sectorielle c'est
quelle est la valeur que le client
attribue au produit final et cette
valeur dépend si c'est des renouvelable
si c'est des back carbone dépend de la
traçabilité des certificats de
durabilité et comme sur l'énergie
renouvelable qui fait aujourd'hui des
garanties d'origine donc un mécanisme de
d'échange de ces droits là qui
permettent avec un certificat qui soit
le même de durabilité qui permet d'avoir
une économie globale et une profondeur
de marché pour que ces grands
industriels et et transporteurs puissent
investir massivement et de façon et de
façon importante là-dedans donc ça c'est
très important je pense que la partie la
valeur du produit final qu'est-ce que
c'est le la traçabilité les certificats
associés et la partie garantie d'origine
je pense que c'est un élément très
important qui manque alors c'était prévu
une partie est prévue déjà parce que la
France était partie en avant ça des
février 2021 leur donne envie de
prévoyait ça donc la traçabilité et puis
les certificat d'échange bon ça pas
encore été mis en oeuvre on le souhaite
mais je pense que c'est un sujet très
important voilà donc aujourd'hui pour
finir conclusion l'ambition est là
l'ambition européenne ambition française
est là on est parti la France est partie
avec l'Europe avant tout le monde
d'ailleurs quand on regarde des projets
qui sont en développement l'Europe est
encore est encore devant l'IRA à
l'énorme avantage après ce que je viens
de dire d'être plus simple et
automatique donc pour schématiser l'IRA
c'est une aide à la production
qui est sans contrainte et qui est
automatique particulièrement on respecte
des des critères et qui dépend
effectivement du du niveau du niveau de
carbone dans la production et elle peut
s'ajouter à d'autres mécanismes de
subvention ce qui n'est pas le cas pour
partir en Europe et donc cette
simplicité
va être en fait le à mon avis le défi
majeur de la France et de l'Europe pour
essayer de garder l'avantage que
l'Europe a et que la France a sur la
partie et la partie hydrogène biométhane
c'est un sujet un peu plus local c'est
un peu un peu différent c'est pour ça
que je parle de l'hydrogène et de ces
dérivé pour ça voilà je vous remercie
merci monsieur
Arbaud un beau là pardon
pour cette introduction tout compte fait
avec un développement fort intéressant
et complet je vais passer la parole à
notre apporteur monsieur Vincent
merci Monsieur prudent merci Monsieur le
Directeur général c'est exposé qui était
qui était dense avec une stratégie
claire sur le biométhane et sur
l'hydrogène qui était d'ailleurs assez
volontaire et on peut s'en réjouir
une question quand même sur ce qu'on
entend parfois ça descend l'hydrogène
qui est la critique sur le niveau de
rendement
et sur l'intensité électrique est
nécessaire à la production et donc
parfois certaines ONG nous disent que
c'est pas forcément la solution
de fait de ces deux ces deux points je
récuré de vous entendre
là dessus sur le biométhane vous nous
avez indiqué que la première génération
a été mature je crois qu'il y a pas trop
de débat là-dessus par contre quel est
votre appréciation réelle sur la
deuxième génération j'ai compris qu'elle
devrait décoller qui avait 300 terawatts
de biomasse tel était l'objectif je
crois peut-être noter un petit peu vite
mais ça serait bien que vous nous disiez
parce qu'il y a un petit débat sur la
deuxième génération sur sa maturité
industrielle et commerciale qu'est-ce
qu'elle est votre votre point de vue là
dessus vous avez abordé le kérosène
synthétique aussi avec deux projets si
j'ai bien entendu
on voit que les compagnies on voit les
recevoir dans un échéance qui est pas
très proche encore mais on voit les
compagnies parfois souscrire des
contrats un petit peu partout et donc
nous cette mission est aussi là pour que
on arrive à trouver des solutions pour
la décarbonation alors je précise que
c'est pas seulement le décarbonation des
transports notre champ va aussi jusqu'à
l'industrie mais on voit cette cette
recherche de solution et on souhaite que
la France n'échange pas une dépendance
contre une autre histoire capable
d'avoir une filière souveraine donc tout
ce que vous faites nous intéresse de ce
point de vue là mais est-ce que vous
serez capable de fournir le besoin de
l'aérien si cette option là est bien
et bien retenu
s'agissant des des kérosène et puis
enfin juste d'un mot je vais essayer la
parole aux collègues
j'ai bien aimé votre votre conclusion
vous nous dites la France est partie
avant tout le monde elle est toujours
dans le Pelton avec l'Europe quelque
part mais finalement les États-Unis ont
une stratégie peut-être plus clair plus
limpide plus simple alors question c'est
qu'est-ce que vous aimeriez que
la France et l'Union européenne face
pour rendre tout ça plus simple plus
clair plus efficace
la parole
merci pour ces questions toutes légitime
valable et ce qui nous pose d'ailleurs
des questions intenses sur le rendement
de l'âge 2 est sur la RT des ressources
c'est pour ça que on dit toujours l'âge
de ce sera en priorité destiné au
secteur qu'on peut pas et qu'on peut pas
décarboner avec les certifications
directs donc ça c'est clair donc d'abord
en électrifie et puis quand on peut pas
électrifier quand c'est pas possible pas
souhaitable trop cher et il y aura il y
aura autre chose et c'est l'âge de donc
c'est l'hydrogène renouvelables de la
carbone peu importe qui qui est
aujourd'hui et c'est pas nous c'est nous
qui disons à travers la voix de nos
clients donc c'est des clients dans leur
processus qui ont fait l'analyse les
aciéristes les cimetiers c'est eux qui
nous disent ça donc là-dessus j'ai pas
de doute autre que leur propre
convictions qui qui est importante quand
vous parlez un ArcelorMittal cimentier
ils disent tous nous il nous faut de
l'âge de ils en veulent tout de suite
maintenant ils veulent ça au même prix
bref en gros ils veulent de la molécule
ma conviction c'est que si j'avais
aujourd'hui l'hydrogène renouvelable
qualifié des Fmbo à même à un prix très
important je pense qu'il y aurait des
gens qui en prendraient parce qu'il y a
tel besoin volumétrique quand a été le
surco sur 1% de pourcent leur propre
consommation et je crois qu'il pourrait
le prendre ne serait-ce que pour valider
la démarche et valider la séquence on
sait bien que l'hydrogène
aujourd'hui la filière est pas très
mature il y a toute la partie je n'ai
pas parlé mais des électrolyseurs qui
doivent monter en gamme aujourd'hui
c'est c'est un électrolyseur alcalin ou
PM c'est quand même 1000 euros du
kilowatt et c'est cher même si ça a
baissé fortement on s'attend
effectivement avec les volumes et les
projets c'est pour ça que j'ai parlé il
faut des projets parce que cette filière
là aussi va va baisser va augmenter
je dirais la déficience du procédé et
aussi va baisser des prix mais pour ça
il faut des projets donc tout ça va
venir je pense qu'il faut il faut être
aussi un peu patient ça peut pas se
faire comme ça tout seul mais encore une
fois nos nous disent il y aura besoin
d'hydrogène et je pense que il faut
avoir en tête l'électrification direct
si elle est possible d'abord et après si
c'est pas possible
l'hydrogène après sur la rareté des
ressources de la biomasse et autres je
crois que là effectivement il y aura et
c'était pour ça que l'Europe et d'autres
pays notamment l'Europe du Nord on voit
les importations comme étant nécessaire
et d'ailleurs s'il y a tel rapidement
parce que c'était que l'Allemagne
l'Allemagne à ce plan qui s'appelle Edge
tout global qui est en gros une double
enchères où il y a une enchère à
l'arrivée de la molécule hydrogène
vecteur de l'hydrogène et après une
enchère pour le marché allemand celui
qui qui bide le plus le plus haut à
cette molécule et donc ils sont en train
de s'organiser pour importer parce qu'il
voit très bien que malgré tout le
renouvelable qu'ils ont mis sur leur sur
leur sol qui est très important ils ont
des plans de développement durable très
important à l'Allemagne et ça suffira
pas à avoir à des carbones et les autres
usages donc et c'est là où quand on dit
il y a une rareté de la matière première
la biomasse ou renouvelable c'est vrai
en Europe mais c'est pareil partout dans
le monde il y en a qui sont et beaucoup
beaucoup de pays qui sont très
excédentaires en renouvelables pas cher
et qui savent pas quoi faire en fait et
qui sont là pour dire tiens il y a une
occasion je vais essayer de trouver une
chaîne d'export donc ça à nuance et
deuxième question sur les la biométhane
donc deuxième génération
oui elle est elle est elle est pas
mature d'un point de vue juste TRL donc
les ce qu'on se construit comme être
comme étant maintenant on a quand même
un projet nous qui est qui est
aujourd'hui en face de pilote avancé et
on a un projet qui va être construit en
au Havre donc on est quand même assez
serein sur l'industrie les
natustrialisation de cette technologie
après c'est comme tout c'est
effectivement
j'irai la concurrence de la ressource
parce que là c'est de la ressources non
pas comme la comme numéro un déchets
alimentaires agricole mais c'est les
ressources résidus de forestiers et CSR
et là il y a effectivement peut-être la
concurrence des usages après sur notre
vision que devrait reprendre la CNBC et
la PPE les 300 terawatters donc c'est
140 terawatts de de biométhane
génération 1 et donc en fait la partie
génération 2 c'est plutôt 80 terawater
et le sol étendre pour la méta-nation
qui est encore un autre procédé
alors pour la fourniture pour les
besoins de des compagnies aériennes
alors je crois que je balance pas trop
en disant qu'on n'arrivera pas à fournir
tous les tous leurs besoins en France en
tout cas pas dans le court terme parce
qu'il faudrait énormément de ressources
et éoliennes offshore parce que bon il y
a l'éoliens
et le solaire est peut-être en plus
limité en France il faudrait énormément
de ressources on le voit pas aujourd'hui
donc peut-être que demain dans 10 ans et
ça sera le cas mais en tout cas dans les
10 prochaines années je ne vois pas ça
arriver donc on va essayer
nous aujourd'hui de proposer deux grands
projets qui vont qui vont essayer de
d'amorcer la pompe et de données ces
éthiques qui redonnent synthèse
compagnie aériennes et puis il faudra
soit accélérer très significativement
développement des parcs éoliens soit
avoir un traitement de l'hydrogène bas
carbone donc nucléaire en France qui
soit un peu différent et c'est là où la
question de la valorisation du produit
final par par la par le client donc est
très importante c'est-à-dire
qu'aujourd'hui ce que nos clients c'est
que les rfnbo c'est valorisé ça ils
savent bien valoriser par contre
l'hydrogène bac carbone le diabète en
détail mais l'application de ce que
c'est notamment les
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
etc correspondant tout ça doit être
encore mis dans les dans les dans la loi
dans les décrets pour mettre sur de ce
que ça veut dire et c'est en lien avec
le système d'échange de permis CO2 qui
est en Europe parce que bien sûr
qui a la valeur c'est soit ce qui
empêche d'avoir une taxe ou un coup donc
c'est c'est le TS sont en Europe par
exemple donc si on peut effectivement
s'affranchir de de de ces de ces permis
CO2 qu'on doit remplir notamment pour la
Syrie bah ça a une valeur ou alors c'est
parce que les clients veulent payer plus
cher mais aujourd'hui ce qui aurait fait
une BO c'est clair on sent qu'il a
marché ce qui est
essayé de remplir une obligation
d'incorporation c'est clair parce que
c'est une obligation ce qui ce qui
empêche effectivement de racheter des
droits carbone c'est aussi clair par
contre la valeur du bac la valeur du du
bas carbone ça c'est encore à définir
donc ça c'est peut être une solution
pour accélérer plus vite plus fort sur
la partie hydrogène
pour les compagnies aériennes et puis
sur l'IRA
alors oui ils sont partis après
d'ailleurs l'IRA aujourd'hui c'est un
stade qui n'est pas un stade d'exécution
donc il y a encore pas mal de sujets à
développer et un sujet qu'on a aussi en
Europe qui va être un sujet qui est très
débattu et ça ça peut faire une grosse
différence plus que la partie simplicité
c'est aujourd'hui la définition de ce
que de ce qu'est l'énergie renouvelable
en Europe donc les actes délégués les
deux disent qu'il faut il y a des
critères d'additionnalité mais la France
s'en soustrait grâce au nucléaire mais
il y a surtout un critère de temporalité
donc jusqu'à 2030 on peut faire une
temporalité de un mois donc le
production renouvelable
est estimé en fait sur une patte temps
un mois après c'est horaire à partir
2030 2037 demain ça veut dire que quand
vous regardez par exemple le premier
champ éolien offshore français qui est
en activité quand vous regardez ces
publics la production vous voyez qu'il y
a des jours entiers où il n'y a pas de
devant d'accord donc comment on fait
dans ce qu'on fait c'est que
généralement on essaye de développer
encore plus de surdévelopper les
renouvelables pour compenser ces
ce manque ce manque de ou c'est ta
terminant et puis si on peut pas on tire
sur les réseaux il y a d'autres
mécaniques des calculs
sur l'IRA c'est pareil à ce débat là
mais l'IRA peut choisir le pas de temps
mensuel et si le choisissent ça fera une
grosse différence par rapport à ce que
l'Europe a mis sur pied aujourd'hui qui
est en fait qui va donner lieu à un
surinvestissement du développement parce
que c'est très difficile c'est
impossible s'assurer que à chaque heure
de la journée il y aura du renouvelable
c'est pas possible donc ça c'est un
point de détail mais qui est un point
important donc j'irai simplicité pour
l'IRA ça c'est sûr on peut cumuler c'est
automatique c'est très important on
remplit alors qu'aujourd'hui en Europe
c'est un système de guichet donc on sous
on soumet notre projet qui est validé
etc
l'irra c'est automatique c'est plus
simple c'est automatique
ça fonctionne en fait les crédits
d'impôt enfin la base fiscale des
banques souvent donc en réalité c'est
pas c'est pas c'est pas la filière qui
empathie et donc voilà donc c'est plus
simple et il faut il faut avoir dans le
détail d'applications parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas encore
applicable il faut avoir si c'est
vraiment plus simple et si c'est
vraiment ça un coup d'accélérateur ou si
finalement ils vont aussi mettre des
freins pour éviter que ça coûte trop
cher aux États-Unis donc à voir voilà
monsieur le rapporteur
on va enlever le haut seulement ça
merci merci pour votre exposé je vois
qu'il y a des fortes ambitions et elles
sont bienvenues parce que on en a besoin
moi mon interrogation c'est sur la
soutenabilité
sur le sur le méthane le biométhane
voilà vous avez des ambitions de 140
terawatt-heure vous dites 80 kilowatts
je crois d'ici 2030 si je dis pas 60
plus tôt 7030
on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui sur la
biomasse il y a déjà il y a déjà des
tensions je prendrais juste l'exemple
des déchets de bois parce qu'on parle
beaucoup des déchets de bois mais on
voit que il y a des réseaux de chaleur
qui s'installent tout autour des villes
avec avec des chaudières qu'il appelle
beaucoup de bois on voit que dans les
biocarburants de seconde génération et
bien on parle également d'utiliser ces
déchets de bois pour la
pyrogazéification là aussi on a besoin
de bois donc on s'aperçoit que tout le
monde retombe sur un peu les mêmes
gisements et ils ne sont pas non plus
en excédant en France et ils sont finis
vous parliez de pays qui avait des
excédents j'aimerais bien savoir en
biomasse de à quel pays vous pensiez et
effectivement je comprends bien que pour
l'hydrogène on a des pays qui ont des
potentiels en solaire qui sont assez
impressionnant
en Espagne Portugal mais en allant de
l'autre côté de la Méditerranée on a
d'énormes potentiels donc voilà c'est
sans doute des possibilités là mais qui
viennent interpeller notre besoin de
souveraineté et voilà donc il va falloir
faire je pense pas des choix mais avoir
des des choses des choses qui se
complètent une question sur l'hydrogène
on l'a vu souvent comme une possibilité
de stockage mais vous nous dites que
dans l'état actuel des connaissances et
des possibilités en fin de compte on va
réserver vraiment si hydrogène à des
besoins spécifiques donc qu'en est-il
est-ce que un jour on peut espérer avoir
des rendements et des prix de cette
hydrogène qui pourraient en faire
vraiment un élément de stockage parce
que comme vous le dites je regarde
souvent les productions
en renouvelables en ce moment on est à
1300 MW en éolien et il y a il y a 3
jours il y a deux jours on était à 14000
donc effectivement on a une fluctuation
très très importante donc il y a
toujours la question la question qui
revient tout le temps du du stockage
voilà sinon dernier élément sur le
méthane
aujourd'hui on a une question
d'appropriation d'acceptabilité des
méthaniseurs on a surtout un besoin on a
travaillé ensemble avec Pierre people
sur le sujet sur le partage de la valeur
et voilà une diversification des revenus
des agriculteurs et aujourd'hui quand on
voit engie arriver dans le paysage
certains s'interrogent si engie ne va
pas capter une grande partie de la
valeur et que les agriculteurs ne
deviendront plus dans l'avenir que des
apporteurs de biomasse et que ce qui
apparaissait pour eux comme et bien à
une
occasion d'avoir des revenus
identifiés sur sur 15 ans ça a peut-être
s'évaporer donc voilà je voudrais savoir
un petit peu comment vous voyez cette
cette question du partage de la valeur
je pense que c'est essentiel merci
merci excellente question également
peut-être pour commencer par la dernière
donc l'acceptabilité j'ai tout à fait
d'accord je pense que c'est c'est un
point essentiel d'ailleurs la filière
apathie un petit peu de ça un peu des
confusions dangerosité partager la
valeur nous on a comme objectif 10% de
part de marché c'est pas c'est pas
énorme donc je sais pas vraiment pas un
sujet d'autres sujets plutôt à nous
c'est de être sûr que dans la filière
chacun respecte un cahier des charges
qui soit professionnel responsable pour
être sûr qu'il y ait pas d'incident
méthaniseur qui est discrédit toute la
filière je pense que c'est commun à
l'énergie pas que pas que au méthaniseur
mais c'est très important et on voit
aujourd'hui aussi que les méthaniseurs
français sont de petites tailles si
garantit pas les effets d'échelle on
voit en Allemagne dans les dans les pays
du Nord d'ailleurs dans les pays du Nord
ce sont ceux-là qui sont les plus
avancés sur la partie
biométhane la Suède qui ont des qui ont
des vraiment des des stratégies autres
avaient des très grands très grands
méthaniseurs et aussi très grande Bioré
friendrie raffinerie bio donc ça c'est
pas c'est pas un sujet par contre
attention acceptabilité attention
surtout au cahier des charges que chaque
chacun respecte dans cette filière là
après sur la l'âge de donc remontant un
petit peu vos questions hydrogène
possibilité de stockage oui c'est une
ambition c'est c'est vous voulez très
bien dit si on partage tout à fait cette
ce jugement il faudra pour que les
renouvelables donnent leur plein effet
sur sur l'énergie et le mix énergétique
de demain et qu'on puisse se débarrasser
des éléments en carbonés il faudra une
molécule qui soit stockable ça c'est
certain ça sera un gaz vert on pense que
ça sera l'hydrogène pourquoi je n'ai pas
parlé parce que j'en ai parlé brièvement
mais c'est dans un second temps et pour
ça il faut il faut d'abord
l'infrastructure qui qui soit compatible
donc on a on a des tests on a
aujourd'hui à Aytré on teste une cavité
saline qui n'est pas utilisée pour du
gaz naturel et on teste l'ensemble du
cycle donc injection après bien sûr ce
que fait l'hydrogène dans la cavité vous
savez l'hydrogène s'échappe de partout
donc le sujet d'hydrogène c'est vraiment
le contenir et après sous tirage et donc
c'est un projet actif un confinement
avec des aides aussi publics confinement
ça a été très pour savoir comment ça se
passait mais donc ça il faut une chaîne
complète pour que ça puisse fonctionner
donc c'est comme aujourd'hui il y a une
chaîne complète du gaz du gaz naturel on
le stocke on le soutire et les tuyaux
desserts des clients et centrales à gaz
il faudra qu'elle est la même chose pour
qu'il déficient de la brique stockage de
l'hydrogène puisse se dérouler la chance
que la France a c'est qu'on a nos
cavités salines le long du long du rôle
là donc l'artère et c'est aussi l'artère
que l'on voit comme étant l'artère qui
sera l'épine dorsale de l'infrastructure
gazières donc gazières verte donc
hydrogène hydrogénoduc européenne h2med
c'est ce que va passer par là et donc
c'est c'est
cavités salines qui sont contrairement
aux aquifères qui ne sont pas propres
qui sont propres à stocker l'hydrogène
son stocks qui sont vraiment localisés
pas loin donc c'est une bonne nouvelle
donc non bien sûr on compte dessus sur
le prix vous mentionnez le prix comme
une question oui le prix c'est une
question aujourd'hui on est en 2023 donc
avec ce que j'ai dit à savoir des aides
bien alignés une simplicité
l'ambition est là les renouvelables qui
vont quand même monter en puissance les
électro fabricants électrolyseurs qui
vont faire baisser les coûts etc etc
donc une maturité qui va qui va croître
avec le nombre de projets et la taille
des projets il faut il faut viser 3
euros le kilo à l'horizon 2030 je pense
que c'est possible c'est volontaire mais
c'est possible et je pense que à ce prix
là et ou un peu moins il y aura de il y
aura beaucoup d'appétit alors sur les
renouvelables et sur et sur la
souveraineté je pense que c'est
c'est pas incompatible c'est pas
compatible de dire notamment on va
produire localement pour consommer
localement et de dire il y aura
d'importations parce que le renouvelable
est quand même répartie dans un nombre
très important de pays un peu
contrairement aux hydrocarbures donc je
vois ça comme complémentaire
je trouve que si la soutenabilité la
transition énergétique en terme
financier pour pour l'économie pour les
particuliers et d'un point très
important et donc je vois pas pourquoi
on se priverait
vu qu'il y a quand même pas mal de choix
notre proche de l'Europe mais aussi plus
loin d'avoir de renouvelable en
surabondance moins cher et alors toute
façon il y a le sujet de quel type de
transport donc peut-être effectivement
on peut le transporter va des tuyaux
sous forme gazifié l'Afrique du Nord ça
serait ce qu'elle est moins cher sinon
ça sera sous forme de dérivée de
l'hydrogène mais je pense qu'il faut il
faut il faut concilier deux je vois pas
de
la souveraineté industrielle en dépend
énergétique sur 21 industrielle je
trouve que les deux sont les deux sont
importants et puis sur la soutenabilité
de la biomasse alors nous on est surtout
focalisé sur la biomasse de première
génération donc quand je disais 300 BC
c'est plus de 140 heures de biomasse
première génération où là il y a pas de
conflit d'usage parce qu'en fait ce sont
des déchets alimentaires c'est les bouts
d'épuration c'est et puis sur la partie
déchets agricole c'est c'est pas ce ne
sont pas les fruits qui qui ont le sucre
comme pour les biofyouls c'est vraiment
l'écorce c'est c'est les agriculteurs ne
savent pas quoi en faire donc là je
crois que là-dessus en termes de conflit
d'usage il y en a pas sur la deuxième
génération vous avez raison donc ce sont
les CSR les combustibles soyez des
récupération et aussi le bois des donc
des déchets forestiers et autres là
effectivement il y a il y aurait qu'on
fait d'usage pour pour produire de la
chaleur ou produire autre chose donc les
pays qui sont qui sont sur AB ondants en
Europe il y en a pas énormément c'est
surtout historiquement la Russie le
Canada les pays du nord de l'Europe et
c'est sûr que ces filières là peuvent
effectivement avoir des conflit d'usages
merci
Martine verte peut poser des questions
qui d'autre parce que on va pour
respecter l'horaire non c'est bien alors
Martine
merci beaucoup Gilbert messieurs merci
je suis très heureuse tout d'abord de
voir votre optimisme concernant
l'hydrogène car on a souvent du négatif
c'est ce que mon collègue disait donc
voilà ça c'est très bien
je confirme qu'effectivement les
industriels donc moi je suis sénatrice
de la Savoie un département où il y a
beaucoup de d'industrie sidérurgiques et
je confirme que les industriels sont
vraiment en attente d'hydrogène vert
certains sont même prêts à mettre en
oeuvre une solution localement pour eux
si cette hydrogène vert n'arrive pas à
suffisamment vite mais ce dont ils ont
besoin parce que c'est déjà le cas pour
l'énergie électrique par exemple qui
leur est fourni actuellement ce dont ils
ont besoin effectivement c'est d'une
qualification précise de cette origine
verte la quantité verte pour pouvoir
eux-mêmes qualifier leur production
vis-à-vis du carbone donc là il y a
vraiment une forte une forte demande
donc voilà peut-être vous en avez parlé
mais est-ce que vous pouvez préciser un
peu plus et puis aussi une question sur
les réseaux
alors vous avez parlé de ces cavités
salines enfin des réseaux etc mais les
réseaux des derniers kilomètres quand
arriveront-ils financement là aussi il y
a des attentes je pense à Tokai kobeix
carbone Savoie qui attend
impérativement ce gaz pour pouvoir
mettre en oeuvre sa production de
batterie électrique
voilà donc quel financement dans quel
délai quelles construction quelle mise
en oeuvre et puis une dernière question
c'est alors vous en avez abordé un
instant sur la sécurité justement par
rapport à l'hydrogène quelles études
vous avez effectué sur le niveau de
sécurité à mettre en oeuvre au niveau
des usages merci
le sujet plutôt j'ai décarbonations
plutôt électrification et sur
l'hydrogène plutôt produire localement
pour consommer localement ce qui rend
les choses plus compliquées pour
effectivement l'interlande française
parce que contrairement à ses voisins il
faudra un besoin d'infrastructure
au-delà des ports pour acheminer la
molécule au stockage et puis aussi
aux économies qui sont aux industriels
qui sont pas à portée de à portée de
porc par exemple c'est par exemple pas
ce qui a choisi l'Allemagne les Pays-Bas
à la Belgique qui sont en train de
travailler et subventionnés un maillage
de réseau sur toute la frange de
l'Europe du Nord qui est très industriel
comme vous le savez et pour essayer de
mailler tout ça donc il faut il faudra
attendre un petit peu j'espère que avec
de m'aide et avec la nouvelle PPE SNBC
il y aura des subventions il y aura un
démarrage d'infrastructures c'est pas
parce qu'on voit la façon dont un peu
plus tard qu'il faut pas travailler là
dessus on sait que ça prend beaucoup de
temps il y a tous les permis il y a tout
tout ce qui est proprement de
recalibrage de certains réseaux de GRT
GrDF donc son offivals qui font ça mais
ça prend du temps et donc il faut s'y
mettre des maintenant c'est ma
conviction après sur la sécurité vous
avez raison le l'hydrogène est un gaz
très volatile et qui peut être dangereux
avec une certaine sous pression en
contact de la de l'oxygène donc il faut
il faut voir que ces gaz là on les
utilise déjà aujourd'hui dans centrale à
gaz donc c'est quelque chose qu'on va on
est on n'est pas les seuls mais on est
collectivement les industriels
connaissent ce gaz là donc il faudra
bien sûr avoir les règles de sécurité la
formation
sur un de nos projets celui avec Total
justement on a
un partenariat avec avec les pompiers de
Marseille donc il y a des formations sur
sur zone qui se sont passées donc tous
les opérateurs seront formés sur ce sur
les risques de l'hydrogène et comment
les prévenir donc bien sûr ces prix
d'ores et déjà dans le développement de
nos projets on a ça en tête
c'est un point très important
effectivement
merci
[Musique]
merci monsieur le Président vous avez
tout à l'heure abordé la question chez
le directeur général de l'hydrogène et
du stockage alors bon on a compris que
c'était les cavités salines sur lesquels
vous travaillez est-ce que vous pouvez
nous en dire un petit peu plus on
dévoiler des choses qui n'auraient pas
dû être public et qu'est-ce que ça peut
apporter demain comme comme solution
ensuite sur les conditions de succès que
vous allez aborder tout à l'heure là on
a compris qu'il y avait un sujet sur
certificat de biométhane sur garantie
d'origine sur les prix de sortie
peut-être que vous pourrez nous
détailler alors soit maintenant soit
sous forme écrite ou après mais ce sera
intéressant pour nous de voir de votre
point de vue ce qu'il faut améliorer
et puis puisque vous parlez de l'IRA bon
on entend dire qu'un certain nombre de
grands investisseurs de grands
industriels ce disent qu'il y a une
opportunité là-bas alors est-ce que vous
êtes en train de réorienter un peu vos
investissements et comment l'Europe
pourrait-elle vraiment se remettre à
niveau et des annonces mais est-ce que
ça vous paraît suffisant de ce point de
vue là
sur
l'enjeu de captation de carbone
pour Fabrer fabriquer des carburants
synthèse on a compris que les
industriels sont en attente de
visibilité de la réglementation
européenne là-dessus qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez d'accord
alors sur ce dernier point catalan
carbone effectivement utilisation de du
CO2 donc
il y a eu dans les dans la filiation des
actes délégués 2 qui sont encore soumis
au Parlement européen et au Conseil de
l'Europe et il y a eu en fait maintenant
des objectifs qui sont assez clairs à
savoir qu'on peut utiliser le carbone
donc le CO2 pardon qui est émis par
l'industriel jusqu'à 2040 donc ça ça
peut rentrer
dans la fabrication par exemple d'un
d'un fioul synthétique de synthèse donc
en combinant ce CO2 là avec l'hydrogène
passer des mi-40 début 41 on n'aura pas
le droit donc ce sera du CO2 biogénique
donc du soyez pas par exemple qui est
mis par les méthaniseurs qui est un
autre notre point intéressant c'est
qu'on peut capter facilement et
réutiliser ce CO2 biogénique des
méthaniseurs mais par d'autres les
stations d'épuration par exemple au
captage direct dans l'air donc passer
des mi41 maintenant on sait ce qui est
assez court les industriels les plus tôt
pour 2045
mais voilà donc ça donne quand même un
petit peu de temps jusqu'à 2040 pour
utiliser ce CO2 le capter sur sur les
processus et après elle réutiliser pour
créer des fiouls synthétiques alors
après il y a effectivement c'est
peut-être ça de votre question il y a en
parallèle à tout ça parce que ça ne
suffira pas il y a des besoins de capter
et de stocker le CO2 parce que en
réalité tout ça ne suffira pas et donc
notamment chez les très gros émetteurs
comme les cimentiers de siristes au-delà
du changement de processus au-delà de
l'utilisation d'hydrogène il faudra
aussi capter stocker et donc le captage
est stockage de CO2 effectivement là on
attend un petit peu de savoir
je crois que c'est le mois prochain il y
aura il y aura une discussion sur les
sur les gaz à effet de serre au niveau
de l'Europe pour savoir comment
comptabilise tout ça mais effectivement
sur le CCS et CCAS comment comptabilise
ça c'est pas encore encore bien clair
alors sur l'IRA nous on est présent en
Europe on est présent aussi aux états on
a une base installée importante
notamment dans les renouvelables donc on
va regarder ça bien entendu on va
regarder les mérites on va pas forcément
arbitrer l'un par rapport à l'autre
aujourd'hui les Américains ont eux-mêmes
énormément de choses à faire pour leur
propre décarbonation de leur industrie
et donc que il est fort à parier qui
vont commencer par décarboner leur
industrie
la question se pose peut-être pour les
entreprises qui sont internationales
dans les secteurs industriels notamment
les engrais les raffineries est-ce que
par un Yara pas le nommer elle va
arbitrer sur une décarbonation de ça de
ces procédés de posions d'engrais au
Texas par rapport à ce qu'il est en
Europe donc ça c'est plutôt ça le sujet
et c'est pour ça qu'il faut attentif
parce qu'en réalité elle est très grands
industriels c'est peut-être moins vrai
pour ceux qui sont moins répartis dans
mes très grands industriels pourront
peut-être arbitrer l'un contre l'autre
et c'est d'ailleurs ça qui a à mon avis
poussé l'Europe les États membres à se
serrer les coudes et essayer de réagir
mais on va on va y par écrit peut-être
sur ces sujets certifications et ces
sujets aussi de quels sont des
contraintes que l'Europe a mis pour
décider qu'un rfnbo était renouvelable
parce que c'est assez précis c'est assez
contraignant et parce que c'est ça qu'il
faudra regarder en parallèle de l'IRA
pour savoir précisément si l'un va
rapidement gagner par rapport à l'autre
donc le diable est dans les détails par
contre ce qu'on peut dire c'est que
quand même l'ensemble du paquet européen
même s'il va dans le bon sens même s'il
est très bon tarif et très contraignant
pour qualifier l'hydrogène vers de vert
que certes les États comme la France et
la Suède aussi qui ont un mix très
décarboné sont avantagés parce que le
caractère additionnel des renouvelables
et n'est pas n'est pas requis et parce
que les cibles sectoriales notamment
pour industrie sont rabaissés si
effectivement on peut produire de
l'hydrogène à partir du nucléaire donc
ça c'est bien et par contre
la définition est donc les
certifications de l'hydrogène
renouvelable ça ça reste ça reste ça
reste un sujet contraignant après sur le
stockage donc nous on a une ambition de
capacité d'intérêt de stockage de
hydrogène en 2030 donc ça veut aussi
dire que de à cette horizon là on estime
et donc c'est en lien avec notre notre
objectif de 700 km
de de
transport de gaz de l'hydrogène donc
c'est lié et donc on considère qu'à cet
horizon là il devra y avoir
effectivement du stockage et des
infrastructures et donc ça pourrait
effectivement servir des régions qui
sont qui sont peut-être plus éloignés
des des centres logistiques
on travaille dessus dès à présent j'ai
mentionné le projet à Estrées pour les
appels hipster donc nous on sait que ça
va fonctionner donc c'est pas vous
faites des études technico économiques
on sait que ça va fonctionner maintenant
un stockage tout seul non rattaché à
l'infrastructure ça sera pas grand chose
donc il faut qu'il infrastructurer le
stockage des deux vont ensemble on a
aussi un projet dans le sud dans la rue
dans la région
après je prévois du Sud près de
Marseille qui s'appelle high green qui
est là pour effectivement relier le
bassin de Marseille en fait à la haut
potentiel solaire qui plus dans les
montagnes essayer d'avoir une
canalisation on a aussi des stockages
ici et d'avoir une espèce de de
d'intelligence à la maille de Marseille
et la région de PACA pour essayer de
profiter de l'industriels qui sont qui
sont à Marseille et puis et puis le
trop-plein de l'hydrogène donc qu'on a
on peut le stocker ou l'intermittence on
peut le stocker et après il y a une
canalisation qui permet effectivement
d'alimenter la zone de La Mède et de
fausses donc ça c'est aussi à l'étude et
donc on va essayer de travailler sur les
permis mais ça s'apprend du temps donc
mon message principal c'est toute façon
il faudra de structure il faudra du
stockage ça prend du temps donc il faut
s'y attaquer dès maintenant ne laissons
pas les voisins du nord de l'Europe nous
nous contourner et profiter peut-être du
soleil
marocain algérien ou portugais et
espagnol en passant en nous contournant
je pense que la place de l'Europe
aujourd'hui un système énergétique et
central pas uniquement comme pays de
production mais comme pays de transit
aussi et ce serait intéressant de garder
pour l'hydrogène pour le futur c'est ce
rôle là
oui juste un dernier point peut-être sur
la partie emploi compétent est-ce que
vous avez des besoins particuliers
est-ce que c'est un sujet sur lequel il
faut que on s'attarde pour enfin il faut
toujours s'attarder sur ces questions là
mais ce qu'il faut un sujet qui mérite
de d'être renforcé et ce que vous avez
des pistes alors c'est un sujet qui est
primordial parce qu'en réalité c'était
quand même un nouveau secteur émergent
donc
les capacités d'attirer les jeunes des
jeunes talents qui sont déjà formés
préformés et plus compliqué je pense
qu'il y a énormément de jeunes
ingénieurs qui veulent travailler dans
ce type de secteur parce que c'est
effectivement l'une des pistes pour
résoudre l'équation renouvelables et
efficace et secteur et intermittents et
stockage donc ils sont très intéressés
donc il va falloir que tout à chacun
nous les autres nous formions des
bataillons d'ingénieurs à ça on s'y
attelle pas tout seul avec la filière
aujourd'hui c'est normal je pense c'est
le plus important c'est vraiment qu'il y
ait des projets qui soient qui soit mis
en oeuvre à la taille à la maille à
industrielle parce que ça pourra remplir
les batteries des
usines de gigafactory sur la partie
électrolyseur et monter en compétences
et pour baisser les prix des
électroviseur ça pourrait effectivement
attirer et former les talents de demain
dont on aura besoin et c'est pour ça que
c'est très important aujourd'hui vu que
un kilo d'hydrogène renouvelable c'est
un peu plus de 50% liés au prix de
l'énergie renouvelables et puis le reste
c'est c'est 40% sur la partie
électrolyseur et système autorise
autoriseur et le reste c'est des coûts
et des coups classiques d'investissement
il faut vraiment fléchir du renouvelable
sur l'hydrogène vert ce qui est pas fait
aujourd'hui parce que sinon ou alors
avoir un mécanisme automatique un peu à
l'IRA parce que sinon je crains que ça
vienne
ça viendra forcément mais un peu trop
tard pour qu'on puisse bâtir une filière
d'excellence en Europe et c'est ça le
sujet je crois que le sujet c'est moins
quand est-ce que ça va venir c'est
aujourd'hui le renouvelable bien n'a pas
assez donc il est cher avec les critères
qui sont imposés par l'Europe c'est
compliqué d'utiliser ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui et donc il faut essayer de
de
fluidifier le système et d'accélérer
aussi la mise en application des
ambitions parce que elle sera partie
législative réglementaire il faut que ça
il faut que ça aille plus vite notamment
sur la partie certification et traçage
et garantie d'origine
bien messieurs monsieur Sébastien
arbolat merci de vous avoir accordé du
temps et merci
bénéficier de votre éclairage et puis à
Monsieur Thierry Riven au plaisir de
vous retrouver sur la métropole de Lyon
et éventuellement pour prochaine station
Grenoble clairement ou Dijon
merci merci merci
à vous